ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่แอดตี้น้องเรียมสวัสดีครับ
นักเรียนสวัสดีครับว่าว่า
มาเรียนภาษาไทยกับพี่อาร์ตี้เรียนภาษาไทย
กับเรื่องห้องเรียงกันนะครับวันนี้โอเค
แล้ววันนี้วันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกันวัน
อะไรครับน้าวันนี้วันอะไรครับวันนี้วัน
อาทิตย์วันนี้วัน
อาทิตย์อยู่ตรงไหนครับวันอาทิตย์วัน
อาทิตย์อยู่ตรงนี้วันอาทิตย์นี้วัน
อาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันที่ 7 หมอ
วันอาทิตย์วันที่เจ็ดอีวันอาทิตย์ที่ 7
เดือนอะไรครับเดือนนี้เดือน 5 พฤศจิกายน
เดือน
พฤศจิกายนโอเค 1 เดือน
รถยนต์แล้วปีนี้ครับปีนี้ปีคศอะไรครับปี
ค.ศ 2000  21 อ๋อนี่คศ 2010  21  15 แล้ว
ปีพตอะไรครับปีพศ
2564 ปีพศ
2564 เข้วันที่อาทิตย์ที่ 7 พฤศจิกายน
2010  21 หน้านั้นตอนนี้นะครับตอนนี้กี่
โมงแล้วนี่ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วครับตอนนี้
14:00 น 14:00 น
02:00  51
02:51  5 นี่ 02:51 น
หน้าเราเรียนภาษาอุ้ยดีกันนะครับวันนี้
เรียนเรื่องอะไรนะครับ
วันนี้เรียนเกี่ยวกับเรื่องของกินข้าวของ
กินเดี๋ยวเพียงตินี่มาแล้วหิวหรือยังครับ
หิวไหม
ค่ะหิวไหมเฮียตี้หิวแล้วขี่อยู่แล้วงาน
อยากกินกินแล้วน้าวันนี้ลูกสาวลูกสาวก็
หิวแล้วนี่คนนี้เป็นลูกสาวลูกสาวคนนี้
กำลังทำอะไรครับ
ลูกสาวกำลัง
กำลังจะกินกำลังจะกินว้าววันนี้ 5 ลูกสาว
กำลังจะกินอะไรครับจะกินอะไรครับวันนี้
ให้กรอกให้อ๋ออ๋อมีไส้กรอกไส้กรอกอยู่ตรง
นี้นี่ดูสิว้าวมีไส้กรอกอยู่ในจาน
ทำไมกรอกอยู่ในจานมีไส้กรอก gion อยู่ใน
จานครับกี่อันมีไส้กรอก 1 อันขออ๋อมีไส้
กรอก 1 อันอยู่ในจานผมพ่อลูกสาวกำลังอยาก
กินลูกสาวตอนนี้เป็นไงครับดีใจดีใจนี่มี
ใจจะได้กินจะได้กินไส้กรอก
เค้กไข่ด้วยค่ะพี่อ้อในจานในจานมีไส้กรอก
แล้วก็มีไข่ด้วยนี่มีไข่ไข่อยู่ในจานอ่ะ
ไส้กรอกไส้กรอกอยู่ในการฐานโอเคน้องเรียม
อยากกินไส้กรอก
อยากกินมีการด้วยใช่ไหมครับอ่ะพี่อ่ะไป
ค่าก็สวัสดีก็อยากกินไส้กรอกหน้าอยากกิน
ไข่น่าก็เอาบนโต๊ะนี้ครับบอลตอนนี้นอกจาก
มีจานไส้กรอกมีไข่แล้วมีอะไรอีกครับมี
แก้วมีน้ำ
อ๋ออ่อนี้
แก้วหน้ามีน้ำเป๊ะน้ำอะไรครับทำไมน้ำเป็น
สีส้มครับ
น้ำไหล่อยู่ในแก้วครับ
เตรียมคิดว่าเป็นน้ำ
แครอทอ๋อ
เป็นน้ำแครอทน้อน้ำแครอทแครอทเป็นยังไง
ครับน้ำแข็งหลอด
แครอทเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ไปไหนทพอดี
ยังไม่เห็นอ๋อ
แครอท
อ๋อ on  What แครอทหรอแครอทเป็นสีส้มใช่
ไหมเราเอามาทำน้ำน้ำแครอทอ๊อดโอเคแล้วก็
อยู่ในแก้วนะอ่าอ้าตอนนี้วันนี้ลูกสาว
กำลังจะกิน
ไส้กรอกกำลังจะกินขายขายแล้วก็กินน้ำ
แครอทด้วยโอเคเอาแล้วตอนนี้ตอนนี้ลูกสาว
เด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้ลูกสาวคนนี้กำลังทำอะไร
อยู่ครับกำลังเขย่าเขาถืออะไรอยู่ครับ
เนี่ย
คือขวดซ้อนขวดซ้อนอ๋อขวดซอสมีควรซอสมีฝา
ฝาปิด
ฝาปิดอยู่ข้างบนตรงนี้ใช่ไหมครับอ่ะแล้ว
เขาไม่เอานะครับเขย่าๆขอซอสไข่เอาไข่เอา
ทำไมครับเขย่าทำไมเจ้าทำไมเขย่าจะได้บีบ
ออกมาง้อจะได้บีบใส่ลงมาในไส้กรอกอ่ะใส่
ลงมาในข่ายอ๋อโอเคกำลังเขย่าเขย่าเขย่าๆ
แปลกๆแบบนี้
ใช่ค่ะ
หาแล้วครับครับไม่เห็นลูกสาวใส่ต่างหู
ด้วยข้ออ้างโหเปียดีเห็นหูหูอันนี้หูแล้ว
ต่างหู
อันเล็กๆอ้อนี้ใช่ไหมครับต่างหูต่างหู
ต้องนี้
ต่างหูต่างหูสีอะไรครับ
มีต่างหูสีขาวต่างหูสีขาวทำไมใส่ป่างหู
ยินดีเป็นผู้ชายเปียตี้ไม่ใส่ต่างหู
her ตานี้เป็นผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงใส่
ก็ใส่ต่างหูเตรียมก็ใส่ป่างหูเหมือนกัน
หรอผู้หญิงใส่อ่างหูแหมแม่แต่ตอนนี้ผู้
ชายก็ใส่ต่างหูน้องนะคะพี่เบียร์ตี้ไมล์
สายเพื่อที่ไม่เคยใส่ตีไม่มีไม่มี
ต่างหูผู้ชายก็ใส่ต่างโหๆ
ได้ผู้ชายก็สั่งได้ผู้หญิงก็ใส่ได้ใส่ได้
อ้างศ.
RE  KR เตรียมชอบชอบใส่ต่างหู
เหมือนเด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้เด็กผู้หญิงคนนี้
ก็ชอบชอบใส่ต่างหูโอเคอ่ะเดี๋ยวที่เห็น
อันนี้อะไรครับเนี่ย
อะไรครับทำไมโขทำไมเด็กผู้หญิงมีอี
ออนผมผมค่ะแล้วเขาเขามัดไว้เหรอครับ Mask
White โอ้โห 5  March เอาไว้ผมผมก็เลย
เป็นแบบนี้
ใช่ค่ะแต่เรียมผมเตรียมปล่อยผมอ๋อโอเค
ครับปล่อยผมก็จะลงอ่ะแบบนี้ใช่ไหมค่ะ
อร่อยผมอ้าโอเคแป๊บเด็กพี่คนนี้ไม่ได้
ปล่อยเขามัดไว้เฮ้ยวัดผงฮาตอนนี้น้อง
เรียมก็กำลังมัดเหมือนกันแต่ผม
อ๋อเคเคากลับมากลับมากินไส้กรอกกันต่อพี่
HD อยากกินไส้กรอกแล้วมากินที่ขอการหิว
ค่ะเขย่าเขย่าขวดซอส B ซอสออกมา
RB ซอสอ่า
ตั้งใจพยายามบีบห้ามบีบแรงนะครับตอนนี้บี
แปรงเลยมีแรงนะครับอ่าอ๋อนะเหมาที่ Arty
ไม่มาประการมีแปลงบีบบีบ 5 บีบแรงแรงบีบ
แรงแต่ซอสออกมาไหมไม่ออกยังไม่ออกต้อง de
อื่นๆนี่มีฟาร์มใช้เหรอค่าแรงเยอะอ่าใช้
แรงเยอะเนี่ยที่เห็นเห็นลิ้นลิ้นลูกสาวๆ
นี่ลิ้นออกมาเพราะว่าอยากกินแล้วอยากกิน
แล้วก็ต้องบีบอย่างแรงมาก
แต่ก็ยังไม่ออก
หน้านี่ซอสอะไรครับทำไมไม่ออกซอสอะไร
เรียงคิดว่าซอสมะเขือเทศอ๋ออ๋อเป็นซอส
มะเขือเทศอยู่ในขวดนี้เหรอครับซอสมะเขือ
เทศและซอสมะเขือเทศทำมาจากอะไรครับ
ทำมาจากมะเขือเทศอ๋อก็ซอสมะเขือเทศทำมา
จากมะเขือเทศอ๋อเราก็เลยเรียกเรียกว่าซอส
มะเขือเทศหน้า
คะใช่ค่ะของ 5
ซอสมะเขือเทศมีสีแดง
มะเขือเทศมีสีแดงใช่ครับสีขายแพงก็บีบออก
มาก็จะเป็นสีแดงแบบนี้แต่มันไม่ออกไม่ออก
เจแล้วถ้ามันไม่ใช่ซอสมะเขือเทศมันจะเป็น
ซอสอะไรได้อีกครับเตียงคิดว่าจะเป็นซอส
พริกอีกไหมอ๋อมีซอสพริกด้วยโหซอสพริกทำมา
จากอะไรคะทำจากคลิกขอซอสพริกทำมาจากพริก
เราก็เลยเรียกว่าซอสพริกอาซ้อตบิ๊กมีสี
อะไรครับ
ซอสพริกมีสีส้ม
ซอสพริกมีสีส้มเหรอครับมีสีส้มแล้วพริก
พริกก็เป็นสีส้มเหรอครับมี
วุฒิมีสีเขียวสีแดงสีส้มมีสีเขียวสีแดงสี
ส้มอ๋อ
หือมีพริกเขียว
พริกเขียวครับ o  o คลิกแดง
พริกเขียวพริกแดง
แล้วก็มีพริกสีส้มอ๋อมีพริกสีส้มด้วยอ๋อ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ซอสพริกมีสีส้มใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะทิศ
สีส้ม 5 ทัพและซอสมะเขือเทศมีสีอะไรครับ
เขื่อเทศมีสีแดงซอสมะเขือเทศมีสีแดง
เตรียมน้องเรียมชอบกินชอบกินซอสเทพ
ว่าหรือชอบกินซอสพริกทัพเตรียม
ชอบกินซอสพริกอาน้องเรียนชอบกินซอยพริก
อ่าแล้วพี่อาร์ตี้ชอบซอสมะเขือเทศ asos
petite ชอบซอสมะเขือเทศแล้วก็ชอบซอสพริก
ด้วยเพื่อที่ชอบ
2 ซอสเลยซอสพริกซอสมะเขือเทศพี่ก็ชอบชอบ
หมดเลยนะกดบีบซอสมะเขือเทศๆใส่ซอส 5 ใส่ 2
2 ซอสเลยอ่าซ้ายครับแต่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ได้
ได้กินหรือยังครับบีบยังไม่ออก
บีบไม่ออกบีบไม่ออกเลยมีครับหน้าเดี๋ยว
เรามาดูกันว่าเด็กไอ้ตัวนี้จะบีบยังไงต่อ
อ้าโอ้โห
เออตอนที่เด็กผู้หญิงขึ้นมา
ยืนยืนบน
เก้าอี้แล้วตอนนี้ยืนบนเก้าอี้แล้วเพื่อ
ที่จะบีบแรงมีนา
ใช่ค่ะตอนนี้
RB แปลงมาก
ใช่มาอยู่บนเก้าอี้นายยืนยืนบนเก้าอี้บน
เก้าอี้ๆครับหน้ายืนบนเก้าอี้แล้วก็บีบ
บีบซอสมะเขือเทศ
นะอ่าอะซอสมะเขือเทศไม่ออกยังไม่ออก
ฮือ
ตอนตอนแรก
เด็กผู้หญิงนั่งอ๋อเออก็ใช่ครับตอนแรก
นั่งอยู่ตอนแรกนั่งอยู่อ่ะนั่งบนเก้าอี้
บนเก้าอี้ชายแต่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ยืมยืน
แล้วหน่ายืนแล้วก็บี่บี๋บี่ห่าแล้วซอส
มะเขือเทศออกมาไหมครับออกไหมออกขอขอบทำไม
ไม่ออกตอนนี้อาหารเด็กผู้หญิงเริ่มเป็น
อะไรครับหาย Love โกรธแล้วโกรธแล้วถ้า
อยากจะกินหิวแต่ซอสมะเขือเทศไม่ออกมาให้
ออกโรตม์
btr1 รีบรีบแรง 5 บีบแรง
เรียนเห็นเหยือกอ๋ออ่อนี่มีเหยื่อน้ำ
ข้างในถ้าเป็นน้ำอะไรครับน้ำแครอทน้ำ
แครอทน้ำแครอทที่ใส่อยู่ในแก้วมีก็เป็น
น้ำแครอทเหมือนกันโอเคอ้ามีเหยือกน้ำ
แครอทอยู่ตรงนี้
หาง
เปียตีเห็นมีกระจกอยู่ในนี้ด้วย
กระจกล่ะ 5 เป็นกระจกอากระจกเอาไว้มองตัว
เองมองตัวเองที่อยู่ในกระจกอ่ะได้ครับอ่า
ทำไมมีกระจกอ่ะโอเคตอนนี้พยายาม BB จน
เป็นไงครับเนี่ย
หน้าแดง
dpb ปะหน้าแดงเพราะว่าโกรธโกรธใช้แรง
เยอะหน้าก็เลยเป็นสีแดงนะเราก็มีถ้าลงไป
เย้ 5 ตอนนี้ก็ยังไม่ออกยังไม่ออกนะครับ
อ่าฮ่าๆเพราะว่า
พี่ช่วยช่วยลูกสาวบีบอ่ะถ้าพี่ช่วยบีบ
เรียกนี่ก็จะบีบแรงเลยดีบุตรแรงออกมาหน้า
เป็นแบบนี้เลย
ออกมาแล้วกระจายเต็มไปหมดเลย
โอยเต็มไปหมดทุกพี่อาบนบนโต๊ะ
คนเลอะมีส่วนโต๊ะก็มีสองซอสมีซอสในแก้ว
แก้วน้ำแครอทก็มีอ๊อดชายบนเก้าอี้
บนเก้าอี้อ๊อดอ๊อดว้าวบนขา
ขา
ก็มีสอบ 2 อยู่บนกระโปรงก็มีบนกระโปรงก็
มีสองร้อน
ใช่ครับโอเคเบี้ยที่คิดว่าซอส
ทำไมซอสเป็นสีเหลืองครับ
ไม่ใช่ซอสมะเขือเทศซอสไม่สอดแพงใช่ไหมอ่ะ
แต่อันนี้เป็นสีเหลืองอันนี้คืออะไรครับ
เรียงคิดว่าซอสสีเหลืองคือวัดตาดอ๋ออ๋อ
เป็นม้าสตรานเด็กผู้หญิงต้องการจะกินมาส
สาสกับไส้กรอก
ต้องการจะกินมาสสาสกับข่ายอ่ะแต่บีบไม่
ออกแต่ตอนนี้ตอนนี้ออกแล้ว
ออกเยอะเลยเนอะ 5 ออกมาทุกที่เลยบนหน้าก็
มีรถมาสด้าบนเสื้อก็มีมาสตาร์ทสีเหลือง
ห่าแล้วพี่อาร์ตี้ไม่เห็นไม่เห็นมาสตาร์ท
ในจานเลย
ใช่ใช่มั้ยเห็นมาสาดในจานในจานไม่มีฮ่าๆ
แล้วมาสดายูบนเก้าอี้บนกระโปรง
อยู่บนเสื้อหมดเลย
แย่จังเลย
แล้วแม่ก็เดินเข้ามาดูแม่เดินมาดูรูปสาว
บีบีม้า starred คุณแม่ไปทำไงครับคุณแม่
เป็นยังไงคุณแม่หงส์สะเหเห้
ทำไม 5 ทำไมมาสตาร์ทเลอะเสื้อ
I  love กระโปรง The โต๊ะ
เลอะเก้าอี้ที่อาทำไมทำไม
ลูกสาวก็ไม่รู้แต่ในจานไม่มีมัสตาร์ดหน้า
R5 งั้นเดี๋ยวเราเดี๋ยวเราต้องกินไส้
กรอกกินไข่อ่ะโดยที่ไม่มีมาสะนาอีซอส
โอเคอ่ะเดี๋ยวให้คุณแม่ให้คุณแม่พาลูกสาว
ไปอาบน้ำก่อนอาบน้ำ
ๆล้างล้างมาสตาร์ทออกไปนะครับหน้าแล้ว
เดี๋ยวมากินไส้กรอกกับไข่นะครับน้าวันนี้
อ่าสรุปบ้างพี่อาร์ตี้ก็ยังไม่ได้กินไส้
คอ
น้องเวียงก็ยังไม่น่ากินอะเดี๋ยวพาลูกสาว
ไปอาบน้ำก่อนนะครับเลยค่ะแล้วก็ไม่ใช่ไม่
ใช่ซอนมะเขือเทศหน้าไม่ใช่ชุดใจสอนมะเขือ
เป๊าะใช้สอดปีก
ป๋อเป็นมาสสาจหน้าเป็นมาสสาจครับ
โอเค JR แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเปล่าหน้า
เขาหน้าพี่อาร์ตี้กับเพียงพาไปที่ไหน
พาไปกินอะไรอ่า
รอยเมื่อเราถูกฆ่านะคะให้ครับแล้วเดี๋ยว
กลับมากลับมาเรียนด้วยกันกลับมาเรียนด้วย
กันใหม่คราวหน้านะครับวันนี้พี่อาร์ตี้
กับน้องเรียมลาไรก่อนครับอ่าบ๊ายบายอ่ะ
ให้ฟังหาเคอรี่ครับไม่ค่ะพญาติขอบคุณมาก
ครับนักเรียนมก็สวัสดีค่ะพี่สวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียน
บี
ไม่ออก
เลอะหมด